des montants d'argent,
montants servent entre autres à
ce point Normand Grondin.
- Dépister et identifier
souvent une question de vie
ou de mort, particulièrement
lorsl l l s'agit de cancers à
tumeurs solides chez les jeunes.
À l'Hôpital de Montréal
pour enfantrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtt
une technologie de pointururur
y parvenir : des biopsies
liquides, qui pourraie
remplacer les techniques
de dépistage classiq
Leur outil de travail :
une simple prise de sang.
est étudié en laboratoire pourtt
des fragments même infimes de
matériel génétique, de l'ADNeses
premières cellules cancéreuses.
Une information précieuse
pour les équipes médicales.
Dre NADA JABADO, pédia
Hôpital de Montréal pour enfants
- On peut savoiresesesest
le type de cancer, on peut
savoir s'il es-c-c-c-c-c-c-c-c-n
aux traitements en temps réel,
par rapport à des images qui
peuvent prendre du temps
avant se forme et grandisse.
- La difficulté chez l'enfant,
c'est que la signature génétique
de certains cancers est souvent
très difficile à repérer dans
le sang. Mais les technologies
sont de plus en plus raffinées.
de sang, on a une telle
précision à l'heure actuelle
avec les instruments de
qu'on peut le faire.
- La biopsie liquide
présente également::::::::::::::
elle est pratiquement indolore
et ne présente aucun risque.
Le petit Brandon, 5 ans,cacaca.
Mais durant tetetetetement,
il a dû subir de délicates
chirurgicales, des interventions
qu'une biopsie liquide
lui aurait évitées.
et les enfants peuvent éviter
une chirurgie avant le vrai
traitement qui, la majorité
une autre chirurgie,
ça va vraiment aider.
- Ces dernières anné
différentes types de biopsies
liquides ont démontré
leur grande effi
chez les adultes, et certaines
ont été approuvées.
Mais chez les enfants,
- Mon échéancier, c'est que
dans les deux ans, on
de données pour lancer un essai
clinique avec des compagnons.
c'est, chez les enfants,
que ce soit la
- Rappelons que le taux
de mortalité des tumeurs
l'enfant se situe entre
20 et e e e e e e leurs
cellules, cancéreuses ou pas,
se multiplient plus rapidement
Ici Normand Grondin,
ananananananada, Montréa